what started all of the blm protests and
riots
it was the death of george floyd and we
saw that video of the death of george
floyd and everybody was
was aghast looking at that video because
you see a man lying dead on the ground
well the daily mail somehow has gotten
footage of the body cam
leading up to the arrest and
to the eventual knee on his neck
i'm not going to play it i thought about
should i play it or should i not
i think there's something a little bit
morbid
a little bit uh
wrong about playing this video where you
know it's going to end in this man's
death and then the man is dead on the
video
so i'm not going to play but i will tell
you what happens i am i am giving you a
straight rundown if you want to check it
out for yourself you're more than
welcome to
cops come up knock on george floyd's
window he's sitting in his car
and he becomes very emotional and he
starts
sort of yelling and crying and anybody
crucially he isn't cooperating so
finally they get him to put his hands on
the
on the wheel but he seems like his
behavior is erratic
later it appears we found out he was on
drugs then they finally get him out he
says his mother just died that turned
out
that was not true his mother died a
while ago
then he says that he he can't breathe
this is why he's standing up this is you
know not not while he's lying on the
ground
then he refuses to get in the car he
says
he says he won't get in the cop car
because he's claustrophobic he can't be
inside a car but obviously that's not
true because when the cops arrested him
first he was sitting inside of a car so
very very strange behavior it's very
emotional to watch
because he's really he's crying he's
he's become erratic he's
but when you watch the whole footage you
think gosh this is horribly sad
and i don't know what happened here at
the end and i don't know why
you know the guy kept his knee on his
neck even when he wasn't moving and i
don't know any of these things
but overall what the footage shows
is that this was a much more complex
situation than anybody thought
the cops were not just going in and
trying to come out
and kill this guy there was a long issue
here there was a lot of erratic behavior
there was a lot of resisting arrest
it's going to make it very difficult for
this murder charge that they're trying
to throw on the cop to go through
you might say it was an abuse of power
you might say behaved inappropriately
you might even say it was manslaughter
but murder there's just not evidence of
that
but that's not going to get out i
guarantee you that video is going to be
suppressed if you can if you can even
find it still
not the point the reality is not the
point it's the illusion
and it's and it's the fact that you've
got to pay lip service
to the delusion and the fantasy
and the ideology and if you don't pay
lip service to it you will have your
life
ruined all based on a lie
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]